[Applaudissements]
oui mais surya leur émission
exceptionnelle aujourd'hui mardi gras
donc voilà vous allez voir sur tous
déguisés vous allez les voir un parent
bouillonnera qui en train de de décéder
malheureusement les rssi franck blocage
avait dit un parent il a déjà fait un
plot sur tout le monde tu peux déjà
parti à rabat sur la nouvelle star mon
chéri merci quand même
merci merci n'a en tous cas merci d'être
avec nous en direct alors il ya plein de
sujets sur lesquels voilà on va revenir
aujourd'hui bien entendu vous vous en
doutez bien et il ya des gens meurtris
et je vous le dit tout à l'heure dans la
loge ce que je vous raconte tout il ya
eu des petites anicroches
oui entre des personnes de l'équipe vous
allez savoir pourquoi il ya un sujet qui
a fait débat
et ils s'aiment tous mais se disent des
choses et tout à l'heure en loge eu des
échauffourées
il ya eu des échauffourées se dire qu'il
ya eu des shows et les fours et voilà et
donc j'ai dû intervenir et
je leur ai dit écoutez gueuler mais pas
trop fort parce que je suis à côté
j'aimerais bien faire ma petite sieste
avant l'émission
donc voilà on va vous dire de quoi il en
retourne il y aura eric et ramzy qui
vont venir nous voir tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]